the uk was the first country in the
world to administer a vaccine we deliver
the fastest rollout in europe and we've
begun the fastest booster camp campaign
2 with over half a million jabs
delivered yesterday alone
and these achievements made possible by
the extraordinary efforts of our nhs
including thousands of gps and volunteer
vaccinators
have literally saved countless lives and
livelihoods in this country but i need
to speak to you this evening
because i'm afraid we're now facing an
emergency in our battle with the new
variant omicron
and we must urgently reinforce our wall
of vaccine protection to keep our
friends and loved ones safe
earlier today the uk's four chief
medical officers raised the coveyed
alert level to four its second highest
level
because of the evidence that omicron is
doubling here in the uk every two to
three days and we know from bitter
experience how these exponential curves
develop
no one should be in any doubt there is a
tidal wave of omicron coming and i'm
afraid it is now clear that two doses of
vaccine are simply not enough to give
the level of protection we all need
but the good news is that our scientists
are confident that with a third dose a
booster dose we can all bring our level
of protection
back up
i know there will be some people
watching who will be asking
whether omicron is less severe than
previous varan variance and whether we
really need to go out and get that
booster
and the answer is yes we do
do not make the mistake of thinking
omicron can't hurt you can't make you
and your loved ones seriously ill
we've already seen hospitalizations
doubling in a week in south africa
and we have patients with omicron in
hospital here in the uk right now
at this point our scientists cannot say
that omicron is less severe and
even if that proved to be true
we already know it is so much more
transmissible that a wave of omicron
through a population that was not
boosted
would risk a level of hospitalization
that could overwhelm our nhs
and lead
sadly
to very many deaths
so
we must act now
today we're launching the omicron
emergency booster national mission
unlike anything we've done before in the
vaccination program
to get boosted now
a fortnight ago i said we would offer
every eligible adult
a booster by the end of january
today
in light of this omicron emergency i'm
bringing that target forward by a whole
month
everyone eligible aged 18 and over in
england will have the chance to get
their booster before the new year
and we've spoken today to the duval
administrations to confirm the uk
government will provide additional
support to accelerate vaccinations in
scotland wales and northern ireland
to hit the pace we need
we'll need to match the nhs's best
vaccination day so far and then beat
that day after day
this will require an extraordinary
effort
and as we focus on boosters and make
this new target achievable it will mean
some other appointments will need to be
postponed until the new year
but if we don't do this now
the wave of omicron could be so big
that cancellations and disruptions like
the loss of cancer appointments would be
even greater next year
and i know the pressures on everyone in
our nhs from our gps doctors nurses to
our porters all of whom have worked
incredibly hard i thank you i thank them
for all the amazing work that they've
done but i say directly
to those of you on the front line
i must ask you to make another
extraordinary effort now
so we can protect you and your
colleagues and above all protect your
patients from even greater pressures
next year
so from tomorrow in england we're
opening up the booster to every adult
over 18 who has had a second dose of the
vaccine at least three months ago the
nhs booking system will be open for
these younger age groups from wednesday
and that's the best way to guarantee
your slot
but in some places you can walk in from
tomorrow
we will also assist this emergency
operation by deploying 42 military
planning teams across every health
region standing up additional vaccine
sites and mobile units
extending opening hours so clinics are
open seven days a week with more
appointments early in the morning in the
evening and at weekends and training
thousands more volunteer vaccinators and
will set out further steps in the days
ahead
it's because of the threat from omicron
that i announced on wednesday that we
will move to plan b
in england you must wear a face covering
in indoor public spaces and from
tomorrow uh work from home if you can
and from wednesday subject to a vote in
parliament you'll need to show a
negative lateral flow test to get into
nightclubs and
some large events if you're not double
vaccinated
these measures will help slow the spread
of omicron but we must go further and
get boosted now
if you haven't yet had a vaccine at all
then please get yourself at least some
protection with a jab as quickly as
possible
if you've already had your booster
encourage your friends and family to do
the same
we're a great country we have the
vaccines to protect our people so let's
do it
let's get boosted now
get boosted now for yourself for your
friends and your family get boosted now
to protect jobs and livelihoods across
this country
get boosted now to protect our nhs
our freedoms and our way of life
get boosted now thank you very much
so that was the prime minister with the
simple message get boosted now he said
we are facing an emergency in our battle
with the new variant omicron he said we
must urgently reinforce our wall of
vaccine protection to keep our friends
and loved ones safe he went on to say
that there is this tidal wave coming and
two doses of a vaccine simply aren't
enough don't make the mistake of
thinking omicron can't hurt you he said
and then the breaking news this hour
that in england every adult over the age
of 18 who had a second jab at least
three months ago
is eligible for a booster and can book
one from wednesday or even in some cases
go to a walk-in center from tomorrow so
that statement uh coming from the prime
minister let's speak to our political
correspondent kate mccann she's in
westminster for us kate nicholas
sturgeon a few days ago said that a
tsunami was on the way when it came to
omicron the prime minister
saying a tidal wave but the message
couldn't be clearer could it
no and i think couple that with the fact
that earlier on this evening the level
the covet emergency level moved from
three to four and you get a really clear
indication of the sense of concern among
health professionals amongst politicians
about what omicron is going to mean for
all of us over this winter period now
again important to say that we just
don't have the full data yet but i think
the early indications about what this
new variant means are not particularly
promising i think that's why the
government has decided to move quickly
we've also heard today confirmation for
the first time that there are now people
in hospital with omicron whether or not
they have been admitted because of the
virus or that they are in hospital
anyway and that they have the virus that
remains unclear but i think the point is
that it is now circulating fairly widely
in the population and it could easily
cause problems for the nhs if the case
rates are high if it's very
transmissible if lots of people catch it
that means lots of people will get
infected and for some of those it will
be serious and that's why the prime
minister as you say is making this very
ambitious promise to bring forward that
deadline which he had set for the end of
january
to the end of december for everybody
over the age of 18 in england to get
vaccinated now you know that offer will
be there for people if they want to take
it up there is the hope that they will
but we also heard of course today that
around 4.8 million people have had no
vaccinations at all and that remains a
significant problem for the government
that hesitancy that reluctance to come
forward and get any kind of protection
something that the prime minister did
mention and some of the language in that
statement too was i think particularly
stark if you like at the end there
essentially warning that this is the way
to protect our way of life it's not new
restrictions but it is a threat that
actually this is the first post in
trying to make sure that omicron doesn't
overwhelm the nhs doesn't make it really
difficult over this winter period people
now need to go and take up that offer
now we know that the nhs is going to
struggle to give that
to make that offer happen which is why
the military will be involved it's why
we expect there will be new walk-in
centers there'll be longer hours earlier
and later opening for people who work
but it will be all about reaching those
hard-to-reach groups going out into the
communities ensuring that everybody
understands this offer and takes it up
quickly that will be where this
protection really comes into its own and
without it i think the nhs will struggle
but the prime minister will struggle too
because if people don't get boosted if
people refuse to if they think it's not
important or it's not relevant to them
or you know it's only pretty mild it's
probably not going to affect me remember
this is not just about all of us it's
altruistic that's what vaccination is
about at the end of the day it's about
protecting everybody in society i think
if that message doesn't penetrate then
things could get quite difficult and
that's the point where you really start
to see that conversation about further
restrictions
uh as you're speaking kate we've had a
response from uh sikhistan leader of the
labour party to the prime minister's
statement he says it is more important
than ever to get britain boosted to
protect our nhs and save lives the
arrival of the new worrying variant is a
reminder that the pandemic is not over
and vaccines are the best weapon in our
fight he went on to say the vaccine is
safe and effective it protects us and
those around us will always support the
nhs and act in the public interest he
goes on to say we've come so far since
those darkest of days at the start of
the pandemic and then repeats that
message telling people to get boosted
and you mentioned the language that the
prime minister chose to use and
something struck me right at the end of
his statement he said get boosted now to
protect our nhs protect our freedoms and
our way of life do you think there was a
message there potentially to those tory
rebels who are so concerned about our
freedoms being restricted
i think there probably is i think
there's also a broader message to those
that group that i just mentioned there
who are unvaccinated the prime minister
was pretty stark when he was talking
about people who were unvaccinated
earlier on this month suggesting that
there could be a conversation about how
to ensure those people are vaccinated
but you're right to pick up on the
politics of this of course because the
measures that the prime minister has
introduced will need to be voted on this
week there are a rump of conservative
mps who do not like them they will not
vote for them and that's a growing group
and their concern is freedom they feel
the conservative party is about personal
choice it's about liberty it's about
freedom to choose how you behave and
they don't like this encroachment this
constant reaching for restrictions
that's how they characterize it of
course the prime minister is balancing
all of that political turmoil with the
turmoil that's going on in the nhs and
and the potential for that being
overwhelmed too those are two very very
difficult things to make
well to meet in the middle if you like
they're really difficult to reconcile
and so it's an unenviable task for the
prime minister he will get that vote
through because he will have the support
of sakia stamina the labour leader you
heard in that statement there hold some
support for this booster campaign they
have consistently pushed for the prime
minister to do more and do it more
quickly but that question remains about
the politics of this it's rumbling
beneath the surface and no doubt in the
prime minister's mind tonight sitting
there giving that address something that
is unprecedented fairly unprecedented we
saw these previously when we talked
about lockdowns it's not a normal thing
to do for the prime minister to sit
there tonight give that address i think
this was as much about appealing to
those to get a booster as appealing to
his party to say look get behind me
because without them he's really going
to struggle to deliver this i think
okay kate uh in westminster thank you
very much for that uh analysis more
reaction to the prime minister's
comments coming in the first minister
mark drakeford first minister of wales
of course has also issued a statement
let me bring that to you he says we are
learning more about